Allez hop, feinte dans la face, qu'est-ce qu'il y a.
T'as même pas fait exprès !
T'es pas censé être bon toi normalement ?
Allez, bim !
Bon, commence pas là !
Arrête de répéter...
Mais t'es un gamin...
Mais t'es un gamin en fait...
Pfff, donc tu vas tout répéter là ?
Arrête de répéter tout ce que je dis.
Ok.
Arrête de répéter...
Tout ce que je dis, mec ça me vénère !
Mais tu chantes super bien.
Ok, on va s'amuser.
Arrête de répéter tout ce que je dis.
Ok, j'arrête.
Mais qu'est ce que tu fais ?
Tu m'as demandé cinquante fois d'arrêter.
Tu devrais être content, non ?
Filou, va.
Continue de répéter tout ce que je dis.
Continue de répéter...
Tout ce que je dis, je trouve ça super.
Là tu répètes carrément tout ce que je dis...
Au moment où je le dis !
On devrait faire ça plus souvent !